[Música]
hola me llamo luzmila dávila y hoy les
hablo desde el huascarán que sigue
rodeada de muchos glaciares muchas
montañas con una belleza paisajística
incomparable que atrae e invita a ser
parte de ella crecí escuchando que los
glaciares eran fuentes inagotables de
agua que eran recursos renovables que
eran hielos perennes que eran eternos me
dedico y dedicó gran parte de mi vida a
investigar el comportamiento de los
glaciares las bondades y oportunidades
que nos ofrecen pero también he
observado muy de cerca el grave
retroceso que están experimentando yo
como la primera mujer especialista en
glaciología del perú puedo dar fe que no
tenemos glaciares que se renueven o se
recuperen es más los estamos perdiendo y
con ello el agua de hecho si hacemos un
símil en dimensiones vemos que es de 216
canchas de fútbol de glaciares
tropicales en el mundo en el perú
tenemos 148
y hemos perdido ya el 3% que equivale a
6 canchas de fútbol en tan solo 14 años
entonces en nuestro país hemos perdido
más de la mitad de nuestros glaciares
ustedes creen que el perú que es uno de
los países más megadiversos en el mundo
con 18 cordilleras glaciares o nevadas
pueden existir lugares donde ya se
sienta la falta de agua debido a la
pérdida de nuestros glaciares
puedo hablar por ejemplo del nevado
pastoruri
un nevado para todos los peruanos
emblemáticos que en la época de los 80 y
90 ofrecía a los turistas campeonatos
internacionales de esquí y hoy en día ha
perdido más del 65% de su área y solo
tiene un circuito denominado el cambio
climático ya no se puede ingresar a la
glacial ya no se puede hacer montaña la
agonía del pastoruri no solo representa
una pérdida para la población local que
depende mucho del turismo
los glaciares son reservorios que
alimentan los ríos cuenca abajo si no
empezamos a tomar conciencia ahora
futuras generaciones serán las que
hereden poco o nada de lo que tenemos
hoy no van a tener agua no van a tener
glaciares
también puedo hablarles un poco de mi
experiencia en antártica
he participado de dos expediciones
antárticas y delante el 23 y el 26 y he
podido experimentar y observar
directamente el proceso de retroceso que
también es considerable en la península
antártica todo ha significado un proceso
de aprendizaje muy significativo para mí
he ido formándome y generan la
información de tipo glaciológico he
visto y he vivido experiencias desde las
más dulces las más tristes y las más
trágicas enriqueciendo me y amando mucho
más a los glaciares lo que nos ofrece lo
que implica la pérdida del paisaje para
la gente que vive en zonas altoandinas
lo que implica que la gente que usa esta
agua para las diferentes actividades
productivas y sobre todo para la
subsistencia se acordarán que a mediados
de agosto 2016 hubo un terremoto en la
zona sur del perú en el colca en la
cabecera de la cuenca de camaná en
arequipa fue otra de dimisiones un lugar
en realidad donde a donde fue asignada
con un gran equipo de trabajo
esta visita programada al sur del país
sería una de las tantas veces que tuve
que estar lejos de mi hija en primera
razón y motivo por la cual no aceptó y
me desafío desafío a mí ya los que no
creen que las mujeres podemos subir
láseres y estudiarlos ustedes se
preguntarán cuál es la relación de los
pequeños pueblos que existen en el colca
con los glaciares
pues estos pequeños pueblos viven
captando nieve acumulada en las zonas en
las zonas altas por las lluvias
estacionales ya la fecha no existe mucha
población ya en estos pequeños pueblos
debido a la migración ya la falta de
oportunidades que existe en esa zona y
las pocas actividades económicas que
permiten su subsistencia vemos cómo
afecta el proceso del deshielo de los
glaciares de la cordillera chila en esa
misma zona les había dicho que
actualmente hemos perdido la mitad de
nuestros placeres saben cuántas canchas
de fútbol existen en la parte de la
cordillera chila
cerca de estos pueblitos al 2020 tenemos
una aproximación de menos de 11 canchas
de fútbol a propósito de mi liderazgo en
el campo de estudios
de los glaciares donde la cuota femenina
es muy pequeña puedo asegurar que una
mujer puede investigar glaciares en los
mismos gracial es como empezamos en
bàscara es posible aunque esto requiere
y represente un sacrificio por hacer muy
grande sin embargo créanme que valdrá la
pena cada uno de esos momentos que nos
dediquemos a la glaciología es realmente
importante e interesante lo que una
glaciólogo puede aportar en estos
estudios anticiparse al futuro
que eso ya demás
porque el cambio climático es una
realidad
debemos buscar los mecanismos de
adaptación y trabajar articuladamente
entre todos y todas podemos evitar
escenarios apocalípticos futuros
de esta manera dar esperanza de vida
para las futuras generaciones y lo digo
con esa esperanza de madrid que desea
dejar un futuro mejor a sus hijos para
mí un orgullo saber que puedo contribuir
con un pequeño granito de arena en este
campo de estudio y mi pasión no solo
representa a la mujer de hoy sino
persigue el sueño de nuestros hijos
que hereden algo mejor somos muy pocas
mujeres peruanas que se dedican a los
glaciares es cierto pero cada vez somos
más y mi anhelo es que las mujeres como
tú que me estás escuchando se involucren
en la ciencia de los glaciares
en realidad necesitamos que nos
involucremos todos pues podemos aportar
de diferentes formas desde nuestros
propios espacios de estudio donde
conservación
porque si no hacemos algo ahora
lamentaremos perder los glaciares que
gota a gota se agota